oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to black rose now we're
in completely new territory here so
everything that's gonna happen has never
happened to me ever there are a lot of
stream ratings I've seen around this
place
for instance the fireplace that isn't
even a real fireplace it's some kind of
ladder shaft but there's a tough metal
grate fastened over it that appears to
be controlled electronically most likely
by the lockdown system uh-huh I'm
assuming the shaft leads down to the
basement but it must have been sealed
off because it's not accessible from
anywhere down there I wouldn't extend
anything that shocks me as a metal
handle that's been sitting on Michaels
desk for about a month now I asked about
it once out of curiosity but he avoided
giving me a direct answer he told me it
broke off of something I had already
assumed this seeing as it's covered in
dirt and rusted around the edges where
it had clearly been attached to
something for a very long time perhaps
the biggest mystery I've encountered
here's the place Myrtle always went for
privacy what do you mean by that she was
often depressed so she was always going
into the downstairs hall on her way to
wherever it was she went to be alone
however she seemed to vanish the only
place she could have gone from that
hallway is down into the basement but I
went down there one day to ask her
something and I couldn't find her I'm
wondering if there's a secret room
somewhere down there and after all I did
learn from Michel that this building is
from the 1600s long before was ever a
funeral home great buildings as old as
this one sometimes have quite a few
secret areas uh-huh was it also built on
an old Indian burial ground or something
something horribly haunted in every way
don't you dare don't you dare was that
the little kid that likes to scamper
around and things okay so I got to find
sir
a whole lot of Sun but there was some
giggling going on down here
it turns out a lot away I got into the
morgue
by stealing Sullivan's key card from the
office uh-huh
mrs. rains had been in there and forgot
to lock it was right nobody knows
exactly how the kid figured out the
passcode but considering what a flake
his mother is that's probably just
something else she inadvertently
compromised they're burying Sullivan
with a few of his belongings from the
funeral home
I guess because he had worked here for
so long and was so loyal to his job
Michael revealed that one of those
belongings is Sullivan's key card of
course they would need to deactivate it
from the system to avoid any breaches
and the chance that it was stolen but
then again mrs. Raines would be the one
who would do that
I discovered earlier today that Devon
had stolen the system lock override key
as well and hidden it somewhere in the
building
this has got to be the most troublesome
ill-behaved kid I've ever encountered
yeah sounds like you really hate this
kid are you Michael
were you though in the row wrote the
scathing review of might never mind I
can't even talk anymore because my
English box isn't even working so where
those giggles come from huh you having a
giggle make huh grief-stricken man
killed by train after blinding himself
well Oh they've never buried either them
both are still here great so what I'm
thinking there's something written on
the back they say that if you take his
rose he wakes up that's the only way his
coffin will open I also heard that he
also tears you into three pieces if he
catches you oh my god oh oh oh god jeez
they won't find it ever
there's something here labeled the V
room two key okay
goody goody gumdrops I'm so happy who's
whispering I mean who's whispering is
there some secret meat okay I think
they're literally just whispering
whisper whisper whisper he's and carrots
peas and carrots [ __ ] you
oh ok ok alrighty then
that was fun glad that happened let's
never do it again
kachunk got it so we're individual ok
those aren't those definitely are an
eyeball was getting dark I can't see
reveal yourself to me demons reveal
yourself to me
oh those are eyeballs what from what Oh
gargoyles on the walls or no those lions
Oh No dare you dare you double dare you
I don't think I want to I'm pretty sure
I don't want to he's gonna rip me into 3
pieces
hey let's go for it there's no black
origami rules later tough to hoof it ok
now time to run don't run don't run baby
oh my go
bye dang oh crap oh joy
Sullivan James was blind as a bat
Sullivan James fell down flat
Sullivan James is withered and blew
another Sullivan James is coming for you
no I didn't like that bomb I like my
poetry better
okay I saw something
Oh
something just fell where Sullivan was
oh so I just needed to run away for a
whole long time good thing I didn't code
to the place where I was gonna go
because that would have been bad oh it's
a key card oh good I'm so happy that I
have that now it's gonna help me in my
adventure very dearly so anybody else
gonna be I also want to jump out of me
I don't know this why would I know this
why why would I know this I don't know
this Oh count the line between the lines
count the line between the lines what
does that mean what does that mean count
the lines between the lines Oh
the X's have line so it's two six two
six four four would that be it two six
four four two six
damn it okay that wasn't it
all right so count the lines between ah
the other ones aren't between lines so
two four eight two four two four four
two damn it it could just be the number
of objects in them so it'd be one six
one six two five could be it damn it
okay so let's just count literally how
many lines are made so that's two one
two that's nine that's four one two
three four five six seven so two nine
four seven two nine four seven
okay there we go
so it was very literal like how many
lines were drawn including the circles
okay I was thinking about two stupidly
great good to know that I'm very dumb
ooh boy now we seem to have entered a
very strange part of the place the place
where they probably embalm all the peeps
which is probably where there's a lot of
dead restless spirits if that guy's note
had anything to say about it so what do
we got oh good nice and slow exactly
what I like uh okay
am I supposed to look in one of these
hello everyone here is dead pretty much
been killed well okay ghosts in this
house are not like ghosts in other
houses if there are in for something
specific their corpses actually get up
oh good
someone threw the lockdown switch and I
can't get out oh god I finally found the
override key but I'm not sure exactly
where the switch is although I might
have an idea
I remember overhearing a conversation
Michael was having a few months ago
about something which was located
underground aha I'm confused as to
whether or not this underground
locations the main basement where
myrtles confidence I went down there a
while ago and looked around but it
appears to be mostly a storage space
maybe I missed it
the basement is extremely dark even with
a flashlight maybe I need to go search
again more thoroughly
oh good exactly what I've always wanted
to do with corpses getting up and
walking around switch yes
my very life depends on it how do you
the lives of many future Wanderers
launders just stopped one of the most
unsettling things
spero home is that after a while you
start to feel as though it's hanging by
a thread and on the verge of collapsing
he prevented only by the mysterious
force fills the building it's such a
strange feeling maybe I'm not the same
skeptic I was before working here but
where is that damn it's probably
somewhere down there when there's a jobs
good how's it go Kay I'll just be on my
way then
don't even think about it buddy don't
even think about it I'm like a wild
animal
I know ten types are coming through on a
few types of Tai Chi one type of
badminton okay so back down to the
basement I guess guess that's where
we're gonna go okay dope you done
alright that's all the time I have for
black rose right now thank you everybody
so much for watching I'll get right on
the next episode immediately after this
and find out what that kid wants over
there so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video overly
attached girlfriend
No what is that thing